اسرع.
هنا قيادة الخطوط الامامية مركز
القيادة يتحدث عليكم احراق
واتلاف اي بيانات وخرائط عسكرية
ولتتحضر للانسحاب. هذا امر
عسكري. علم وينفذ. بهذه الطريقة
تلقت القوات الاوكرانية امرا
بالانسحاب. في هذه الاثناء قال
يوري مديار قائد اللواء
الميكانيكي الثامن والعشرين
بالجيش الاوكراني قال ان وحدته
الاستطلاعية تلقت امرا من مدينة
شرق اوكرانيا. وطباخ بوتين الى
السيد المحترم. محاصرة. فلتأمر
جنودك بالانسحاب ولكم ثمان
واربعون ساعة فقط.
اصحاب العيون الضيقة وبكين ترد.
الحرب الباردة تندلع بين الصين
وتحالف واليابان تطمئن والسم
ينتشر في المدارس الايرانية
والاوروبيون يصلون فلسطين للرد
على جيش الاحتلال. ايعقل هذا؟
والامارات تفجر مفاجأة لمنظمة
اوبك والنفط ينخفض. بينما تسيطر
موسكو على جزيرتين يابانيتين. ها
هي اليابان تعلن عن اكتشاف جزر
جديدة. الانسحاب الاوكراني من
باخموت. شد وكر وفر بين الاوكران
والروس في مدينة باخموت وبعد
سبعة اشهر من القتال هو مؤسس
مجموعة فاجنر العسكرية الروسية
يعلن ان مدينة باخموت باتت مطوقة
بالكامل. ولم يعد امام القوات
الاوكرانية الا الانسحاب من طريق
واحد وفق قوله مع اعطاء مهلة
للانسحاب بينما قال احد اعضاء
المجموعة ان الجيش الاوكراني بدأ
بتدمير منشآت البنية التحتية
وخاصة الطرق والجسور لعرقلة تقدم
القوات الروسية والهدف كسب مزيد
من الوقت كي تنسحب من باخموت.
ليعلنها يوري ماديار قائد اللواء
الميكانيكي الثامن والعشرين
بالجيش الاوكراني بان وحدته
الاستطلاعية تلقت امرا بالانسحاب
من باخموت. مؤكدا انه سينفذ
القرار رغم عدم معرفته بالاسباب.
فعن اي اسباب تتحدث يا هذا؟ اولم
تعلم بان المدينة قد حوصرت
باكملها؟ ومن باخموت الاوكرانية
الى بريانسك الروسية. حيث وجهت
روسيا اتهاما خطيرا للناتو وقالت
الخارجية الروسية في بيان لها ان
عمليات القتل في منطقة بريانسك
ارتكبت باسلحة الناتو. وهذا يدعو
للتساؤل حول تواطؤ دول الحلف.
واضاف البيان ان خطط الناتو
محكوم عليها بالفشل وفق الاعلام
الروسي ليخرج المتحدث باسم
الكرملين ديميتربسكوف ويؤكد ان
بلاده تتخذ اجراءات اضافية
لحماية الحدود. لترد روسيا ايضا
وبطريقتها الخاصة وذلك باعلان
وزارة الدفاع الروسية اطلاق
صاروخ كروز كاليبر على هدف ساحلي
من غواصة تابعة للاسطول الروسي
في بحر اليابان. واضافت الوزارة
ان الصاروخ اصاب هدفه وتجاوز الف
كيلو متر. كما هو الهدف التالي.
امريكا ردت بدورها. وذلك
باستضافة تدريبات لعسكريين
اوكران في قاعدة تابعة لها
بالمانيا وفق رويترز. لكن الرد
الروسي لا يتوقف. ومع مرور عام
على الحرب في اوكرانيا تلقى ما
يقرب من الف متطوع تدريبات
عسكرية مكثفة من جامعة القوات
الخاصة الروسية في الشيشان.
لننتقل من التدريبات الى معارك
التهديد والوعيد. حيث قال وزير
الخارجية الروسي سيرجي لافروف ان
بلاده لن تسمح للغرب بتفجير خطوط
انابيب الغاز مرة اخرى. واضاف ان
موسكو لن تعتمد على الغرب بعد
الان كشريك في مجال الطاقة.
مشيرا الى ان الغرب لم يتعامل
بجدية مع مخاوف روسيا ولم يحترم
مصالحها. مؤكدا انه سيعاد توجيه
سياسة الروسية نحو شركاء موثوق
بهم. الرد الامريكي جاء من
الاراضي الهندي. حين اعلن وزير
الخارجية الامريكي ان واشنطن
ستحرص على ان تنال روسيا عقابها
على الحرب الاوكرانية لان
الافلات من العقاب سيشجع دولة
اخرى على انتهاك سيادة جيرانها
واحتلالهم وفق تعبيره. ليخرج
متحدث البيت الابيض جون كيربي
قائلا ان الدعم الغرب مستمر
لكييف لتكشف التقارير الامريكية
ان واشنطن ستمد كييف بحزمة
مساعدات بقيمة اربعمائة مليون
دولار. وهنا جاء الدور على
الرئيس الاوكرانيسكي. مستنجدا
بالغرب وقائلا ان القوات المسلحة
الاوكرانية تعاني من نقص في
المدفعية والذخيرة والطائرات
العسكرية والدبابات وطالب الدول
الغربية بتسريع امدادات الى
اوكرانيا. ليضيف ان اوكرانيا
بحاجة للمدفعية لا لضرب الاراضي
الروسية وانما للسيطرة على
المناطق التي استعادتها روسيا
مؤخرا. وها هو يصرخ مجددا. نحن
بحاجة للطائرات ليس بالاقاويل
والوعود وانما ببساطة بتسليمنا
الطائرات وتدريب طيارينا وذلك
وفق وكالة تاز. لتأتي النجدة
والامداد من اوروبا. وذلك الخدمة
الصحفية للمفوضية الاوروبية
اعتزام الاتحاد الاوروبي نقل
خمسة الاف وسبعمائة لوح طاقة
شمسية من انتاج شركة انيل
الايطالية الى اوكرانيا بيان
خدمة الرد الاوروبي السريع على
طلبات زيلانسكي. اما في المانيا
فطالبت برلين سويسرا ببيعها بعضا
من الست والتسعين دبابة ليوبارتو
الموجودة في احتياطي الجيش
السويسري. ووعدت بعد ارسالها الى
كييف حسب ما ذكرت صحيفة بليك.
وبين هذا وذاك وزير الخارجية
الصيني تشينج يانج يعلن رفض
العقوبات الغربية على روسيا
معربا عن دعم عملية السلام لحل
الازمة في اوكرانيا وفق وكالة
تاز. الصين لا تهاب تحالفات
الخصوم. مع كل يوم جديد تزداد
الاجواء قتامة اكثر وترتفع حدة
بين الصينيين والامريكان. وهنا
مزيد من التوتر والتصعيد في
العلاقات الامريكية الصينية. مع
تنديد بكين بالعقوبات التي
فرضتها امريكا على شركات صينية.
وطالبت الصين واشنطن بضرورة
التعامل بعدل والتخلي عن سياسة
القمع. ياتي هذا بعد ان اعلنت
وزارة التجارة الامريكية فرض
قيود تصدير على ثمانية وعشرين
كيانا صينيا بهدف لما تسميه
التهديدات المتزايدة من الصين
للامن القومي الامريكي. فهل يصمت
اصحاب العيون الضيقة اكثر لتزيد
الولايات المتحدة من استفزازها
للتنين الصيني. بتعزيز نفوذها في
اسيا حيث استأنفت في تايلاند
اكبر مناورة عسكرية بالعالم بعد
جائحة كورونا وبحضور ثلاثين دولة
مع مشاركة كوريا الجنوبية ليجتمع
وزراء خارجية دول الحوار الامني
الرباعي المعروف باسم كواد وهي
الولايات المتحدة واليابان
والهند واستراليا. موجهين رسالة
للصين انهم قلقون جدا حيال
الانتشار العسكري في بحر الصين
في مواقع متنازع عليها. لكن
اليابان عادت لتطمئن الصين بان
كواد ليست تعاونا عسكريا بل مجرد
تعاوني. بانتظار الرد الصيني
الاحداث والتطورات. موجة غضب
عارمة اثر حالة تسمم طالت مئات
الطالبات باكثر من ثلاثين مدرسة
في ايران. والرئيس الايراني يقول
ان اعداء بلاده هم من يقفون وراء
هجمات التسميم لتطالب الامم
المتحدة بفتح تحقيق شفاف في
القضية. الدفاع الامريكي برنامج
ايران النووي تقدم بشكل ملحوظ
بعد من الاتفاق. وفد اوروبي يزور
بلدة حوار الفلسطينية ويدعو
لمحاسبة مرتكبي الجرائم بحق
الفلسطينيين وساقولها للمرة
الثانية انتم تكذبون كما
تتنفسون. سجلت اسعار النفط
العالمي انخفاضا حادا بعد ورود
انباء عن مسئولين اماراتيين ان
الامارات تجري مناقشات داخلية
حول امكانية الانسحاب من منظمة
وفق الرجل السوري الذي سافر من
المانيا الى مكة المكرمة على
دراجته فارق الحياة على مشارف
الحرم. وبدلا من ان يصلي في
المسجد تمت الصلاة عليه هناك
ودفن في مكة. بعدما اعادت
اليابان احصاء عدد جزورها فوجئت
بان العدد الفعلي اعلى بكثير مما
كان معتقدا اذ وجدت هيئة معلومات
الجغرافيا المكاني ان هناك سبعة
الاف جزيرة لم تكن محسوبة من قبل
بحسب سي ان ان اهناك احد ينسى
سبعة الاف جزيرة؟ اين من يتحدثون
عن ذكاء اليابانيين وكوكب
اليابان قوات موسكو اصرت على اخذ
باخموت بالقوة؟ وبعد اشهر من
المعارك؟ ها هي روسيا اليوم تخلق
باخموت لتخر صريعا. فما هو
التالي